>> Hello YouTubers.
I'm joining you today to tell you about a
meeting we have in May at the Dead Sea in
Jordan, mid-May 15th, 16th, 17th, where we
will be talking about many of the important
questions that the Arab world is facing.
Now one important one I'd like your help on
is to help us discuss and to see how role
models can make a difference in the Middle
East.
We have one question I'd like you to answer
by uploading your videos, and that is
What are the important qualities that a leader
from business, from science, and from young,
or the young population, the youth should
have to make a difference in the future of
the Middle East.
Please upload your views and your responses
on that, and we will take these responses
to the Dead Sea and share them with our participants,
and they'll become part of the discussion
we have there.
To get a feeling from all of you on how important
you think this subject is, please respond
to our poll by saying yes or no to the question
Do you think role models are important for
the future of the Middle East?
Thank you for your views and your contributions,
I look forward to receiving them.
We will take them and discuss them and will
come back to you also after the meeting in
May.